I understand your issue and your issues
coming from because of the difference in
languages as well Tony when you read
do you read that do you need diabetical
marks there's the purpose
when you look at June news you need it
you don't need it because the context in
the world you know exactly what it is
yeah but if I know that if I know that
that's what I'm saying what do you think
that's okay but who brings this
came in later on but so here's my so you
said by the context because he knows the
context he can know how the word is read
right but like us who don't know Arabic
yeah so that's that's my point my point
in bringing up tabari he was an Arab
right and and he's quoting Arabs and how
they read it differently and so when
they're reading it and they know the
context people there's groups that are
literally saying No this is right versus
no this is right and then tavari gives
his own opinion right so yeah so that's
what I'm saying is like if we don't have
the diacritical marks there's no
objective way to determine which is the
absolute correct reason okay so how
would you again it comes back to so if
you go to a Arabia right now right I've
been Argentina
open up the Quran does not have any
diabetical marks okay but they read it
exactly how I would with the directors
because they know the language so what
the issue that you're trying to present
is a language issue and if you move from
one place to another then language
changes the dialect changes and that's
the argument that you're trying to make
but the letters are the same
[Music]
[Laughter]
because this is again now you're looking
into a very eloquent Arabic it's not the
everyday Arabic like even if I give you
a lot of like difficult Urdu poetry
you'll have trouble like oh is it this
one is this way
the meaning of it I understand what
you're saying that I cannot might I can
read it doesn't matter how it looks okay
no no but the guys are the guy who can
people not reading even that himself he
said I must follow
he said he's a scholar
okay
how do you have any questions
about what are we changing the subject
yeah what's that what are you asking
yeah sure yeah
distribute all over the world right okay
and that's why they make it wonders they
tried to destroy the other ones they
don't available we have a 37 pounds okay
but you don't find any more in the
market because Saudi Arabia did what
he's supposed to do is
you know they give you one Quran but
they don't not want to allow you to take
any of the Quran you know
you know what that is why why wasn't
putting delayed I don't know why why was
it today the reason is that they don't
want anybody to have a problem with
other the citation because that's why we
have a 37. it's to avoid it okay if you
look at the okay so if you look at this
that were given when the printing press
came about is because they were very
strict on it it's like nobody is allowed
to make Mass copies because the way the
printing has started you have to have a
rough copy they have to have those like
in in English you have to have like a
like a template that they use in the
scan and that's what's being copied over
with Arabic a lot of again with the
diacritical marks and everything one
error and now you have a thousand copies
that's gonna get distributed it's gonna
be a big issue so until it was perfected
to take on the Arabic language and the
dialect until then it was not allowed to
okay so how are we going to prove that
Muhammad was a prophet what do you mean
that's fine like when they go back to
the point so why I just want to make
sure about did you agree with my answer
questions
what was your reason why was it today
because I'm telling you that what you're
reading or that's not the same Quran
what you're talking about is it's coming
from same
generation of Team uh Arab languages or
different languages different dialogue
that was
half square is not the same dialogue
it's a different dialogue than English
but the words okay you know like I said
that's fine he already explained to you
about that I mean there is a issues in
there but what my concern is that how
are you going to prove Muhammad is a
prophet
well
first off we look at a slide
three Islamic we have a lot of stories
about that
planes a lot of okay so what's the
difference
regular person came into a prophet and a
prophet which is true that's what I'm
saying half because
that's that's the four that's the base
Foundation right if they're medical so
there are no Miracles now if Muhammad
had Miracles attributed to him yes and
there are eyewitnesses and rooted
Witnesses okay would you agree then show
me the Miracles show you the Miracles
yeah okay now
put on itself is a miracle
so which one is that there's a 37 okay
again you're going back to so there's a
difference between the actual letters
and the critical marks the critical
marks can be different depending on the
place but the word is the same okay
that even that that has a different
letter like one has an alif and one
doesn't yeah so no my question that
which is the original one which is the
thing Say the original Quran
yeah one one of them has has it and one
doesn't they have alif as like an actual
Standalone yeah one has an elephant
critical Mark added to okay so let me
see you you'll know more than I am but
show me and stand alone
he's gonna show me another let's talk
about the moment
as not as an actual letter not as a die
critical well it can I I mean do our
olives
but there is Olive here in Maliki yeah
he's talking about this this Malik that
is does it have an aloe here or no so
you're saying there's gonna be meme
that's a diacritical there's a uh
they're two different variations
so okay maybe we can break this down
later because because so you're saying
that the olive is a is the accent mark
so that that brings that brings the
letter or that does not bring the letter
that's the way those particular Arabs
people speakers in those places spoken
like when I say the word I mean I'm from
Canada I said about I we emphasize on
the you okay so if somebody who's just
hearing is it emphasize on the you but
in American you will focus more on the
O's it's about
so emphasis on the O So when you're
reading Arabic you want to make sure
that this is being recited properly or
as close to as possible
so when you're trying to teach somebody
who does not speak English at all you
say the word about I say the word about
right they're gonna say which one is
correct that's where the diacritical
marks comes in okay but the letters it
seems like there's garlic and money
can you please tell me Quran itself is a
miracle the eloquence of affinity
there's no contradiction
okay very simple for the challenge of
the Quran is produce a book like it okay
right and and produce a chapter like it
all produce a verse like you know this
is a challenge not a big now let me give
you the same challenge in English give
me a verse
wait in English which uses all grammar
grammar rules
introduces new grammar rules which is
not contradict original grammar rules
which uses old words in a new way let me
finish the same let me finish that
subject no we're not no problem you're
asking me for the challenge
even in English give me a sentence
reduces all grammar rules introduces new
grammar rules uses old words differently
introduce new words which everybody can
understand
and it all makes sense in a poetic form
and as concise eloquent way as possible
can you do that in English so I I
believe that Omar did it in Arabic
yeah so he came up with three verses
that made it into the Quran he didn't
come up with it yeah he said he said
that the Lord agreed with me three in
three ways agreed okay so Omar yeah so
Omar said something and the similar it
was revealed in the exact same words yes
he said it yes so so
if we're saying that um produce
something like it what Muhammad said or
not Muhammad sorry what Omar said was
good enough and so much so much like the
Quran that it made it in it that Allah
agreed with it okay so I would say that
Omar fulfilled that challenge
how not thank you
because the challenge is firstly bring
something like it bring something like
it now what he's with the words that
were chosen was also like an importation
you know what it's like a quotation
right so these are the words that have
been spoken let's say if Jesus said this
this person said this when Omar said
something it was not I mean okay I'll
I'll take back my words actually
um that's an excellent question okay
um my our understanding was that Prophet
has said things about Usman oh sorry
about Omar that if there was a prophet
after me it would be um he said that he
said that
if there was a prophet that wouldn't
come after me it would be um that's
interesting yes so that's one of these
things
and it sounds I'm not saying I heard it
before it sounds familiar though but
yeah I believe the fact that that's an
American decoration because there
profit
[Music]
uh Allah were to send a new one it'll be
Omar it'll be Omar okay well we know
that that number happens okay so so for
me then how is it then that Omar who's
not a prophet right was was inspired
enough to say something that was good
enough to be in the Quran three times
[Music]
yeah
that would have to be it's if the Quran
is revelation then that means that Omar
received that Revelation that
inspiration from God at least it
couldn't have been from himself I see
what you think now there are different
responses I don't know the way to
properly answer you okay that's an
excellent point but I would not say that
Omar would be fulfilling the challenge
because the worst was released after it
after Omar said it after Mercedes wait
so you're saying that the challenge came
after Omar said it all right the
challenge
okay so it's mainly again what is the
challenge you have to look at it it says
bring something like it bring something
like it what is it referring to first
thing the karate
so it doesn't say anything like book
number one starts off with that one for
the Arabic people and then it says bring
a chapter like it or reverse like so
Omar brought three persons afterwards
but that was before but I see that's a
very that's a valid argument I'll give
you that you you're different you're
somebody that we could continue these
like we can move on from subject to
subject because you're reasonable so
it's it's bro I see that I don't know
how to actually what the explanation is
I'm sure one of the scholars I've
actually given it I have not read up on
it uh but there are miraculousness that
happened even with the other sahabasas
we're gonna show a miracle in the Quran
to Muhammad which one is it
[Music]
well okay so one thing that was
mentioned in the Quran was the schooling
of the Moon okay
I don't know we'll do right now I don't
know okay I'll give you the book uh yeah
okay what about it so show me which
words is that
um
54 I had one and two the hour has come
near and the moon has split
uh and if they see a miracle they turn
away and they say pressing magic okay
so this was a challenge given to mama
you know this one yeah right it it
doesn't say it doesn't say that Mohammad
but it said that it was a sign of the
hour didn't foreign
doesn't say that Muhammad or that Allah
performed and worked through Muhammad
but that the moon splitting was it it
does not say in the Quran but do you
know the context well a court looks like
for me because I read a lot of the Quran
there's so many places in the Quran that
says that Allah never sent a sign to
Muhammad yeah what that he never sent
the sign to Mom that he was actually
refrained from doing it because if he
did it the people wouldn't believe
anyway so he was like they don't deserve
a sign
like that's chapter 17 verse 59 yes I
know that one
um we're talking about the different
types of Miracles than what I'm
referring to what I'm referring to the
splitting of the Moon and this was
[Music]
um I don't know exactly this happened
and
I don't know exactly when that one was
revealed so I need to look up that one I
know that's there that they keep asking
for the sign but we have sent the signs
to people but even then they yeah they
did the idea is that's exactly what
happened even when the moon was split
they said like oh this is magic so so my
thing is
from what I understand with the verse is
that the people were asking for a sign
and stuff like that right and really the
sign of the uh of the last days of the
hour of the Judgment Day and so the
response is is that
um The Sign of the Judgment Day is that
the Moon is split like that right that's
that's one uh yeah that's one uh right
that's one of the signs right so so it's
not that that's a a miracle being
performed by a prophet but that it's
just a it's one of the general signs
that shows that the hour is coming
again go back into the context of this
what really happened so they were going
into it
each challenge if you split the moon I
will accept this now and a lot of these
Croatian leaders they stood up again
with this point and the moon was split
the scientists
I mean if you look at this point we have
not observed Evolution we don't even
know if Jesus exists by this point oh we
do we do we yeah
we're talking about historically
historically speaking we installed a
historical mechanism and all that kind
of stuff but
here's here's my thing if because what
you're quoting is not the Quran it's a
like the context
yes right so here's my thing is that the
Quran over and over and over and over
and over says that Muhammad never
performed Miracles that he never was
given any signs but that he's just a
Warner over and over again so if the
Hadith is saying that he performed a
miracle it would be contradicting what
the Quran says
but like you know God
[Music]
yeah so like so that God gives him a
sign to to do for the people who are in
front of witnesses the the Quran says
that that never happened that he's only
a Warner we have to look at from the
chronological point of view because a
lot of these verses like you know they
were abrogated Parts as well because one
of them says don't come in near prayers
if you're drunk that kind of indication
like oh you can't be drunk but just get
out during the prayers but another one
says no alcohol is prohibited completely
so there are abrogated verses one place
for another one yeah but these aren't
abrogated like none of these verses are
abrogated about him being the one look
into this again I did not come prepared
to have a debate I can go home and do
research and I come back
do you live do you live around here no I
don't know hey so you're just visiting
I'm just visiting it
and how long how long I'm actually
flying back tomorrow Tango summer
yeah okay well all right well let's
let's keep going you know why are we
happy I'm saying that okay
there's no miracle in the Quran and
Muhammad did it because there's so many
worships are here I can tell you that
Quran said that he is a simple Warrior
and do not asking he's a messenger he's
also says that no what's it now there's
no Miracle okay we don't have any food
because
you're saying the splitting of the Moon
there is no there is
okay back in those days the only proof
that you usually get
[Applause]
okay okay what you're doing is taking
two different things out of context
that's not the right way of doing that
no brother like so this is what it is
because I this is I like to I I try to
treat the Quran like I treat the Bible
like when I read the Bible I use the
Bible to interpret the Bible and stuff
like that like so if I see something to
come I see what it's all said around
about this type type of thing so when as
when I was doing study in the topic of
did Muhammad perform Miracles okay and I
looked in the Quran it's in probably
like seven or eight verses I might be
missing some but seven or eight verses
all over the Quran that are consistent
that he's just a Warner no signs just
the one or no signs they'll believe
anyway I mean they will disbelieve
anyway no signs he's just a Warner right
so it's it's a very consistent theme bro
so if somebody's saying that he
performed a sign all our performance
sign to him giving him a sign I'm like
that contradicts what the Quran says all
over it's consistent you know so that's
I'm trying to be as consistent as I as I
can with the Quran not you know that
argument is a very old argument and
um I've come across this a few months
ago I just I only thing is we have to
look at from the chronological point of
view and we have to look at on the
aggregational point of view again I have
I have to read up on it
but I don't again if if that is what you
say is true
that means that there is a contradiction
in the historical thing that has been
reported yes
absolutely absolutely so if so if I'm
being fair to
oh
my God
yeah
if if we're being honest to what the
Quran says right then I have to I have
to assume or I have to conclude that
okay according to the Quran he didn't
perform Miracles but as a Christian
looking in
we go back to the question okay so how
can then I verify that he actually was
indeed a prophet if no signs followed
him how can I verify that he's a prophet
so that'll be the question still okay so
um
and you probably heard the answer that
I'm gonna give you
and then you walked away
[Music]
oh man okay so
what's your message then my message
because I I need to go do more reading
so what's your message so our message is
that
Jesus Jesus being the Son of God the
Divine Son of God who came in flesh okay
walked amongst us lived the life that we
should have lived we as Sinners we're
Sinners before God right and there's
nothing that we can do no good works
that we can do no not going to church to
a mosque to a synagogue right it's not
enough but we need God to just show us
his mercy and Grace purify us himself
because we can't purify ourselves okay
and but he's since he's holy and just he
can't just sweep our sin under the rug
he has to deal with it right sin has to
be punished so Jesus comes lives the
life that we should live fulfills the
law completely and takes on the law of
Moses the the the moral law the rituals
the things that that make that you know
shows that God's character and his
righteousness this is what I want from
you this is what I demand okay and we
fail at that all of us fail we all fall
short right
um while Jesus came didn't fall short
did it perfectly and so yeah
he then lives the righteous life
perfectly and bestows that righteousness
unto us by his purely by his Purity
we're purified we are purified and now
we have salvation through Jesus Christ
as as the son okay so that's the message
so when you say son of God what do you
what do you mean do you think biological
son of course not because he's God is
Not physical okay so he's a spiritual
son yeah the spiritual son man he died
for our sins yes so he died on the cross
he died on the cross in his human nature
when he took a human nature so it was a
human sacrifice or Divine sacrifice yeah
it's both because one the the the Divine
gave up his uh his position for example
like he made himself with no reputation
it says that he emptied himself and took
on the form of a servant so him being
high and low gave up his his Divine
privileges not that he's like stopped
being he lost his nature nothing but he
humbled himself basically he humbled
himself submitted himself and then took
him the form of the servant form of a
human and physically gave the sacrifice
of dying in that human it was a physical
sacrifice
when it comes to the death correct it's
the physical side the sacrifice that was
required was a Divine sacrifice to
forgive everybody's sin but it was a
human sacrifice that was given them no
no no no no so because because it was a
physical sacrifice right right right but
but the person who did it is divine the
person who is Jesus yes is divine the
soul is divine yeah so the soul doesn't
die correct so it's not a sacrifice no
dead if Jesus cease to exist as a death
doesn't mean to cease to exist I'm
saying that's what I'm saying
oh there she is okay well I gotta get
going but uh you want to finish that
yeah so what I'm trying to say is like
so either it's going to be a physical
sacrifice or a spiritual sacrifice so to
forgive all the sins God has sent
himself or got us God the father has
sent the son the son are they the same
they are not the same person although
they share the same nature the same
nature yeah they coexist yes they
coexist and one person one one person
came down
and then they sacrificed their physical
being yes so it's a human sacrifice yeah
yeah well him being the human so the
human died but also sacrifice forbidden
in Judaism so so this is this is where
like the curse upon God no no no no no
no so no let me let me explain so what
you have going on here is when it comes
to these people that are giving up their
uh sacrificing their infant babies
um killing innocent virgins and stuff
like that yeah unwilling people giving
up for sacrifices while Jesus is a
willing participant who came down right
in his Divine knowledge and will came
down and willingly took on the form of
the servant and willingly gave up his
life then why was he saying oh God
because he's quoting psalm 22.
so he quotes Psalm 22 that literally
talks about exactly what is happening to
him so to the Jews that's around him
while he's on the cross and says oh God
my God why have you forsaken me them who
recite the Psalms all the time knows
exactly what he's quoting so what he's
quoting is a Messianic prophecy that
foretells his crucifixion literally in
Psalm 22 it says they wag their their
tongues at me they mock me they rip my
clothes and it says that they pierce my
hands and my feet
so this is in Psalms a thousand years
before this happens so Jesus is pointing
them to while he's still on the cross to
a prophecy about him
so that they might even still believe
even even at that time okay well I do
have to go but one question I'm gonna
ask you yeah
um so is Jesus according to you is he
always God always human or does he
switch in nature no so him being he
never stops being Divine never stops
being Divine but he did take on the
human nature at a point when he when he
uh was born so if he's Divine he knows
everything correct he knows the future
of the past everything existence that's
happening around that's right that's
right so why in the Bible when he's
approaching a victory he's smacking like
Oh I thought it was a reason why don't
you figure well that's not that's not
what the verse says so the verse says
that he solved its fig tree he was
hungry no it doesn't say that he thought
anything okay it says that he saw the
Fig Tree and he was hungry and he saw it
that it had leaves okay so when he went
to it and saw that it didn't bear fruit
then he cursed it let me tell you why
number one
is that when fig trees have leaves when
they show their leaves it means that
they're bearing early fruit right so
even if it's not in season fig trees in
Palestine would bear early fruit it's
called baraba fruit okay so it's
supposed to Bear the fruit now since
it's not bearing fruit but it has the
appearance of bearing fruit he cursed
the tree because it's not fulfilling its
purpose although it's dressed as it it
was not it was a lesson to the disciples
because before right before they go to
the Fig Tree they was just dealing with
the Pharisees and the religious leaders
and he was talking to them about how
they're dressed and look like have they
have a form of godliness they do the
prayers they walk and they fast and they
show their faces and throw Ash on
themselves they have this appearance of
godliness but because of their heart is
far from them they're cursed so it's the
same with Israel having the form of
godliness the Fig Tree is a
representation of Israel so it's the two
two things going on there it's supposed
it's an illustration that Jesus is not
for no reason that makes sense
[Music]